bonjour massy d'être en direct avec nous
sur rt france alors manifestations un
peu partout contre cette loi dont une
manifestation à paris on vient de le
voir votre position par rapport à cette
loi est ce qu'elle est légitime selon
vous on a dans notre pays à une question
de sécurité qui se posent pour pour tous
les français et en l'occurrence il ya
une demande de davantage de sécurité
ça c'est une réalité et le parti pris de
départ de cette loi en tout cas de cette
proposition de loi qui consiste à dire
qu'il faut assurer un continuum de
l'ensemble des chaînons de la sécurité
pour faire en sorte de répondre à cet
enjeu principal quelques questions de
sécurité ça parle un bon sentiment et
d'une bonne idée ensuite malheureusement
il ya eu des maladresses dans la
conduite de ce texte et notamment
l'article 24 qui a cristallisé
l'attention
là où en réalité ça répondait à un
besoin je pense réel et qui est une
attente des français partout sur le
territoire national
en tout cas michel bassez la haut
commissaire aux droits de l'homme de
l'onu at et la france a retiré l'article
24 du coup cet article sera r écrit
est-ce que c'est suffisant selon vous
vos choix que l'article 24 devait être
réécrit et c'était le rôle du parlement
en l'occurrence l'assemblée nationale et
on aurait dû faire confiance aux
sénateurs ensuite pour procéder aux
modifications utile ce texte à mon avis
lorsqu'il ya un cas très mal écrit il
est mal écrit et je dois reconnaître que
quand le gouvernement annonce créer une
commission ad-hoc pour écrire cette
partie du texte
c'est une maladresse et c'est même
contraire aux principes du bicamérisme
français démocratique et parlementaire
donc quand je crois qu'il fallait faire
confiance au parlement les faire en
sorte que cette partie du texte sont
arrêtés parce que je crois
qu'effectivement telle qu'elle est
écrite aujourd'hui elle ne répond pas
réellement à l'intention de départ qui
est de protéger à la fois les policiers
et de protéger aussi ceux qui peuvent
être interpellés parfois et de manière
marginale disions le par des forces de
l'ordre de manière un peu un petit peu
brutale donc en l'occurrence je pense
que cette partie du texte qui est une
protection pour les deux parties entre
une humaine aurait dû être réduite de
manière peut-être plus subtile et bien
moi je fais confiance au parlement pour
procéder à ces modifications
on est d'accord initialement cet article
devait empêcher ou au moins dissuader
les journalistes de filmer les policiers
en exercice
moi je crois qu'il faut être très
prudent là dessus
la sécurité et la liberté vont de pair
évoquant sa liberté des journalistes à
liberté d'informer est une valeur
essentielle en démocratie et je crois
que pour le coup peut-être la france
plus que d'autres pays ils sont attachés
et pour ma part je vais pas question de
limiter le droit de la presse sur
contraire et je pense que c'est pour ça
que vous le dis la manière dont cette
partie du texte a été écrite était très
maladroite et a concouru à ce qu'on
fasse la malle gamme la sécurité
évidemment la liberté de la presse tout
site est tout aussi évidemment que je
pense que l'interprétation qu'elle était
laide et est extensive et maladroite
je pense qu'il faut revenir à une
rédaction qui garantissent la liberté de
la presse qui garantissent les droits
évidemment informés des français en
toute liberté
et puis évidemment donner la possibilité
lorsque c'est nécessaire et bien de
procéder aux enquêtes pour faire en
sorte que les images servent parfois à
et bien réprimer ceux qui ont cassé et
en l'occurrence malheureusement
nombreuses manifestations ces dernières
semaines
donc il ya des casseurs dans les
cortèges de manifestants et c'est bien
dommage
tout comme d'ailleurs sanctionné les
forces de l'ordre lorsque il y a et bien
des dérapages et pour être tout à fait
honnête mais mon sentiment c'est que on
a un débat qui s'est emballé on a un
gouvernement qui a effectivement mal
communiquer sur ce sujet et qui du coup
a donné lieu à un malentendu général en
tout cas pour ma part je crois qu'il
faut trouver cette position équilibrée
qui permettent de garantir la liberté de
la presse et je crois que vous y êtes en
tant que je réalise très attaché et en
tant que démocrate je suis tout autant
attaché alors cette fois c'est
initialement pour protéger les policiers
pour qu'ils exercent leur mission en
toute sécurité
pourquoi ils ne se sentent pas en
sécurité aujourd'hui en france je crois
qu'il ya un problème de moyens déjà
terre que healy a depuis maintenant
plusieurs années une succession de
crises qui mettent en péril la sécurité
est qui et qui font que les forces de
l'ordre sont en première ligne depuis
déjà très longtemps je pense qu'il ya de
l'épuisement d'épuisement professionnel
ça existe je pense qu'il ya une tension
très forte et qu' aujourd'hui
effectivement ne se sentent pas en
sécurité
et face à ça évidemment qu'il ya
aujourd'hui des images qui choque les
français et donc il ya un divorce qui
qui pointent je ne dis pas
qu'aujourd'hui le divorce existe mais je
pense qu'il peut arriver entre les
français et leurs forces de sécurité
alors moi je me rappelle quand même
qu'il ya encore quelques années lorsque
malheureusement la france étaient
touchées par des attentes
terrible on applaudissait les cortèges
de policiers parce qu'il nous protège
est aujourd'hui malheureusement à cause
d'un certain nombre d' images violentes
c'est vrai lors des manifestations de
gilet jaune puis ensuite avec des
manifestations plus classique entre
guillemets géré par les syndicats on a
eu ces images de violence donc je pense
sincèrement qu'il faut à la fois
réconcilier les français que leurs
forces de l'ordre et puis aussi il faut
donner davantage de moyens à la police
parce que franchement ils répondent à
des situations d'urgence dans des
conditions absolument dramatique et un
manque de moyens criant mais je crois
que tout ça va de pair dire qu'on ne
peut régler le problème de la police et
des risques pour leur sécurité que si on
réconcilie les français avec la pole
leurs polices et montrer que finalement
on ne peut vivre en état de droit que si
on a la sécurité et que si en même temps
on a la confiance des français à l'égard
des forces de sécurité si vous entend
bien le lien est un peu rompus entre la
police et une partie en tout cas de la
population française et puis donc il
faut rétablir ce lien et puis arrive
cette loi pour pénaliser la vidéo
expliquez-nous après le cheminement
comme on est arrivé là alors la
proposition le mans en tant que tel au
départ elle est sur un sujet qui est
beaucoup plus à mon avis opérationnel et
précis c'est comment on fait en sorte de
garantir ce continuum de sécurité police
nationale police municipale et tous ceux
qui contribuent d'une certaine manière à
garantir la sécurité et notamment en
intégrant la dimension technologique
dans la prise en compte tout simplement
de tous les outils utiles pour assurer
la sécurité
c'est ça le point de départ de cette
proposition de loi ensuite oui il ya eu
une évolution du texte qui a fait qu'on
a intégré beaucoup de choses et je crois
que l'une des erreurs fondamentales
c'est de ne pas avoir procédé sur des
sujets aussi sensibles que cela non pas
par des biais de propositions de loi ou
par le biais d'un projet de loi ce qu'il
faut expliquer la différence c'est que
ça aurait permis d'intégrer dès le
départ le conseil d'état qui aurait
procédé naturellement un examen de
dispositions du texte est sans doute
éviter qu'on ait des interprétations qui
puisse paraître liberticide
à mon avis il ya eu là une erreur
fondamentale et c'est vrai que on a
besoin de revoir notre système de
sécurité on a besoin de remettre tout le
monde autour de la table tous les
chaînons de la police de la justice
de la gendarmerie va tous ceux qui
contribuent et la police municipale
évidemment afin de faire en sorte qu' il
ya un continuum et l'idée était bonne
mais effectivement le débat a dérapé
très objectivement il ya sans doute eu
des dispositions ont été intégrées aux
textes n'ont pas été évaluées de manière
juridique suffisamment film en est on le
voit aujourd'hui avec des prises de
position qui montre que certaines
dispositions ne correspondent pas à
l'exigence qu'on peut avoir à l'égard
des droits de l'homme donc je pense
qu'il ya eu une erreur fondamentale dans
l'évolution de ce texte mais pas dans le
point de départ qui à mon avis à prendre
et un besoin raid
d'ailleurs des élus locaux je le précise
daniel leca merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions rappelle que vous êtes
vice-président dans la région et aux
trois ans et vice-président du lieu à
compiègne beauvais je suis désolé vous
offrir c'est tout à fait normal et élus
à compiègne merci en tout cas d'avoir
été en direct avec nous sur rt france